democrats for us to get a little
creative to stop residents from fleeing
their cities New York city mayor Eric
Adams hitting the streets to personally
recruit people to apply for thousands of
vacant city jobs that comes as the
latest IRS data reveals a blue State
Exodus New York Illinois and California
are hemorrhaging High earning residents
to Red States Greg did Eric Adams offer
you a job no it would have been worse if
he was begging for change though but the
irony is it's the citizens who are
begging for Change and it's our it's our
politics and it's our politicians who
walk right by us and go not our problem
not our problem can we all just move can
we just pick up and leave this state
please I'll pay I'll pay for the I'll
pay for the uh yeah the U-Hauls and the
houses on the other side my dogs yes I
just think I admire that Eric Adams is
not somebody who sits back and doesn't
try to actually go and meet the people
and do something however if your pitches
that basically come live in a place
where you can't use gas stoves we want
to ban you from eating meat and then oh
by the way here's a free Apple Air tag
to put in your car because when it gets
stolen we'll be able to help you maybe
get it back and that's if you don't get
shot beforehand
judge I can't say it better than that
the truth is look the blue states are
losing people and they're losing tax
dollars and the red states are gaining
them and this guy is basically begging
but I think he needs to understand that
you know giving someone an air tag is is
not the answer to the problems that we
have in New York City and New York state
it just isn't okay so your thoughts or
if you want to tell everyone how the
fact check on me and Judy Bloom is going
yeah one person Kitty mother in a county
in Florida who's powerful enough that
she got to talk single Judy Bloom Book
Bin from a library from the library and
all you care about is that you didn't
say anything when the president of the
United States was censored or when
millions of Americans were censored over
the lab leak or the laptop
[Music]
oh Judy Bloom what about a million of
Americans banned from using their first
amendment rights yes where were you
I want you to do me a favor I want you
to click to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page this is the only way that I
know for sure that you're not going to
miss any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on Fox you can get it all here on
YouTube so subscribe right now